t'es désormais la seule route qui permet
d'accéder à barmouth
nous y arrivons sous les tirs des forces
russes
Moscou cherche à couper cette dernière
voie terrestre pour l'instant les
blindés Ukrainiens les ambulances
empruntent encore cette route de
campagne mais c'est soldats que nous
suivons son pessimiste
la situation est très difficile pour
nous les Russes sont en train
d'encercler
nous accédons à l'un des sous-sols en
ville où se font les rotations de
soldats entre les combats cet endroit
doit évidemment rester secret
des dizaines de lits superposés
des hommes qui se croisent sur les
visages l'épuisement
l'anxiété
certains dorment d'autres préparent leur
sortie dans les rues pour aller au
combat
les Russes sont tellement nombreux
on dirait des fourmis qui avancent et
nous poussent
c'est difficile de garder nos soldats
vivants et de tenir psychologiquement
l'équipe médicale évacue chaque jour des
blessés et des morts deux jeunes soldats
qui nous donnent pas de chiffre sur les
pertes humaines
quand vous passez votre temps à évacuer
des amis blessés
des hommes avec qui vous combattez
depuis des mois
c'est vraiment très difficile moralement
les sortir de là mais le pire c'est
quand tu n'es plus là-bas l'enfer c'est
ici quand tu réfléchis après le combat
ces soldats se reposent 24 heures dans
ces abris souterrains de la ville de
barmouth il repartent au combat et c'est
une lutte acharnée qu'il nous décrivent
rue après rue immeuble après immeuble
les forces ukrainiennes sont prises en
tenaille attaqués au nord au sud et à
l'est par les Russes
ce bataillon a filmé ces images récentes
de combat de rue
elle donne une idée de ce qu'est l'enfer
de barmouth
nous quittons la ville
pour préserver leurs hommes les
Ukrainiens vont-ils abandonner cette
commune et se replier officiellement ce
n'est pas d'actualité